أجنبي
[موسيقى]
أتمنى أن تكون زيارتي والتواصل فقط
مع الناس في البلدان الثلاثة
آمل أن يكونوا قد رأوا ما نقدره وأنت
تعرف وظائف العائلات
أم التعليم الرعاية الصحية
تغير المناخ أعني أنك تعرف في كل  الثقافة
وهي مهمة جدًا ولذا آمل أنه
ربما يمكن لزياراتي بطريقة صغيرة أن
تغير العقول قليلاً
لأننا لسنا ما أنت كما
وصفتنا للتو على الأقل
هكذا لن أصف
الولايات المتحدة أبدًا  بهذه الطريقة ، أعتقد أنك تعلم أننا
جميعًا عبارة عن GL ، أعني أنه يجب عليك التفكير
في الأشخاص على مستوى العالم ، وفي الحقيقة نحن جميعًا
مجرد بشر وكلهم يدورون
حول التواصل وفهم
بعضنا البعض وثقافاتنا وإيجاد
مكاننا حقًا  لدي أرضية مشتركة ،
نعم
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لقد أخبرتني أنه تم إساءة فهمها.
لم أشعر أنني
شعرت بالدفء فقط من الناس في
مصر والأردن والمغرب في
كل مكان ذهبت إليه ، فأنت تعلم أن الناس
سيقولون الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية  الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية أو أرحب بكم أعلم أنني شعرت
بالدفء فقط من تلك البلدان
[موسيقى]